the thursda started off their press
conference this year in style with a
real-life Bethesda 'land there was vault
boy statues revenant statues and a
ferris wheel I missed it all but what I
didn't miss was the video games usually
just to be here to help me out but she
was hosting our livestream and speaking
of which make sure you're subscribed so
you see all of our news coming out of e3
but for now let's dig into it
everything Bethesda spoke about at their
showcase will be coming out this year
and they started off with two virtual
reality games if you can handle the
motion sickness doom is bringing massive
guns to your virtual space Marine
gauntlets and plenty of baddies to point
the map with doom VFR gates of Hell not
your speed you'll be able to walk the
wasteland build settlements and battle
super mutants in Fallout 4 VR when it
launches this October it's worth noting
that the entire game will be playable in
VR speaking of fallout there'll be a
steady stream of new content for both it
and Skyrim via the newly announced
creation Club things like new armor
weapons and gameplay enhancements made
by Bethesda and collaborating outside
creators will all be purchasable with
coins when the service arrives this
summer on ps4 Xbox one and PC if you're
playing Elder Scrolls legends then good
news the card game is getting dark
brotherhood story content in game
tournaments and a chaos arena most
excitingly a heroes of Skyrim expansion
will hit the game on the 29th of June
when it arrives on ios and android so
soon let's keep that Skyrim train
a-rollin the long-awaited Nintendo
switch version of Skyrim was shown off
along with some very nintendo features
you'll be able to cosplay in links
breath of the wild tunic as well as
wield the master sword by tapping your
link amiibo there are also motion
controls for swords shields and bows
which looks pretty damn cool
unfortunately no concrete release date
has been announced for this one yet but
keep an eye on Nintendo's press
conference for that Dishonored 2 is
getting some DLC in the form of death of
the outsider it stars the quest giver
from the main game Meagan Foster as she
teams up with doubt from the original
Dishonored 2 knife of dunwall DLC the
pair appear to be teaming up to kill the
outsider the source of the characters
powers Meaghan Foster looks to be every
bit as formidable as Emily in Corvo - as
she teleports through walls and skulks
around behind enemies the DLC is set for
release on September 15 Bethesda also
use their showcase to position quake
champions as a major eSport they
announced a sponsored competition for
August 26 during quakecon that will have
a 1 million dollar prize if you want to
get some practice in the
bata has been reopened indefinitely and
you can sign up on the website right now
go go go go go go go go Bethesda closed
their 2017 showcase with two new games
the evil within too and Wolfenstein 2
the new Colossus the evil within too
will launch on October 13 this year and
is being developed by the devs of the
original tango gameworks it was revealed
via a cinematic trailer that looks as
psychologically freaky as you'd expect
from Resident Evil creator Shinji Mikami
the protagonist from the first game is
returning this time in the hopes of
rescuing his daughter closing out the
show was Wolfenstein 2 the new Colossus
and it just might be my favorite reveal
after a fake TV show about a girl in a
giant robot dog BJ blaskowitz was
revealed to be still alive and Nazis
have taken over America there's rideable
robot dogs crazy dual wielding weapons
and a comrade who drops acid yep it's
more of the same crazy action machine
game started with the new order and you
won't have to wait long to play it as it
releases on October 27 this year BJ will
also make the jump to quake champions
where he'll have his own attributes and
voice lines so that's Bethesda for this
year make sure you tune in tomorrow for
Ubisoft and Sony and make sure you grab
the game spot now app so you can get the
top ten news stories of the day
delivered straight to your phone we will
see you tomorrow